العديد من الدول تعاني من زحمه مروريه
خانقه ويبدو ان اضرارها تتخطى الانزعاج
والضجر وضياع ساعات العمل الضرر يصل الى
الجسم وبالتحديد الى الدماغ فقد اظهرت
دراسه جديده ان استنشاق عوادم السيارات
اثناء الجلوس داخل الحافلات وسط تعطل حركه
المرور ساعتين او اكثر يمكن ان يضعف وظائف
المخ والادراك حسبما نشرت صحيفه ديلي ميل
البريطانيه بينت الدراسه نستنشاق عوادم
السيارات يقلل من الاتصال الوظيفي وهو
مقياس لتفاعل مناطق الدماغ والتواصل مع
بعضها البعض وقبل ان ننتقل للجانب الصحي
سالنا الناس في مصر كيف تقضي وقتها
الازدحاب المروري
[موسيقى]
بتماشى مع الزحام المروري بسمع مثلا اذاعه
القران الكريم
والحمد لله اليوم بيعدي يعني بقضي وقت في
مواصلات بلعب جيمز او بتكلم مع والدتي مع
اخواتي فتعلمت ان انا دايما معي
السبحه بتاعتي
وبسكر بذكر الله بقى بكل اسماء الحسنى
الكتيره التي لا تعظ تعد ولا تحصى والله
عادي بقى انا ممكن اقرا قران نسمع مثل لو
في مثلا بنشغل الراديو مثلا نسمع حاجه
اغنيها حلوه بتاع
[موسيقى]
تبقى فتره بتبقى ممله بس الواحد بيفضل
اللي هو مثلا ممكن يقرا مثلا عناوين عن
مثلا عن الرياضه او مثلا ممكن يعني يسمع
قران او اي حاجه مهمه الواحد يقضوا وقت
اللي هو يطلع من الهم اللي هو بيبقى في
الوقت بتاع المرور ده وانا في الزحمه بمسك
التليفون باتسلى اخش على الواتس افتح
الانستا ببجي الكلام دوت اسمع مزيكا
الكلام دوت انا بصراحه انا بحكم ان انا
معايا يعني موتوسيكل فساع بطلع الموبايل
امسك الموبايل شويه اكلم واحد صاحبي كده
يعني اكيد بمسك الموبايل مش هعمل حاجه
اكتر من كده
[موسيقى]
اختصاصيه امراض الصدر والريا الدكتور يسعد
صباحك اهلا بك معنا في الصباح العربيه
التعرض للتلوث التلوث المروري في غضون
ساعتين يضعف وظائف الدماغ الى الدراسه
دقيقه واقعيه بالفعل
الازدحام وتلوث في الهواء
ينقص نسبه الاكسجين في
المخ في المخ نعم
لمده ساعتين فقط يعني في وسط الازدحام
ينقص بنسبه 15% نسبه الاكسجين لنتنفسها
كمان فيها غازات سامه من المحركات
السيارات التي تدخل بس مش بس للقصبات
الهوائيه كمان للقلب للشرايين وللمح كمان
وتنقص في نسبه الادراك
طب اقبال بيقولوا لك انه في خبر جيد في
هذه الدراسه النوم انه هاي الاعراض كلها
كانه مؤقته ما ان يستنشق الانسان هواء
نظيف حتى تعود رئتاه سلمتان هل هذه
المعلومات دقيقه صح اذا كان الشخص سليم
وما عندوش اي امراض اخرى فهذا بالفعل صحيح
لانه المثال الذي يروح في الويكاند ويعمل
شويه رياضه في مناطق خضراء فهذا خلص يعني
ترجع نسبه الاكسجين تطلع في الدم وكل شيء
يرجع تمام بس اذا في مؤهلات مثال جينيه
عند المدخنين ولا في اي امراض القلب
والشرايين مثال اللي بتكون تخلي الالتهاب
في الجسم يكون عالي فيمكن انه لازم يستشير
الدكتور ويعمل ويعمل استكشافات اللازمه
وياخذ دواء لا يرجع كمان 100% انا اريد ان
افهم ما الذي يحصل تحديدا لماذا تتاثر
وظائف الدماغ ما هي الجهه التي تتاثر
ولماذا يكون التاثر في الذاكره واداء
العمل
هو يكون اكثر في الذاكره لانه احنا نسبه
الاكسجين تؤثر اكثر على
الجهه
الفرنسا ننقولها اللي في المخ في
الاماميه وهي التي تؤثر اكثر على
الوظائف
الادراكيه طيب اقبال
تفضلي طيب شو تنصح الناس اللي يكونوا في
الحركه المروريه يا اقبال ويكون هناك تلوث
مروري خصوصا اللي بيعانوا من الامراض اللي
بيعانوا بالامراض انا انصحهم اكيد انهم
يروحوا للطبيب يستشروه وياخذوا الدواء
المناسب وهو كمان لما بنصير سليمين وبناخذ
دواء المناسب باثر كمان على المود بيضوي
هذا الاسبوع اجاني مريض هو اجل الشهر اللي
فات واخذ الدواء وهو كان عنده
كل يوم يسال نفسه اذا هو زعلان ولا اذا هو
يعني
من اللي اخذ الدواء صار كل يوم
كنت معنا في الاستوديو دكتوره اقبال خلف
الله اختصاصيه امراض الصدر وريئه شكرا
دكتور شكرا